アロエベラんこんにちは
今日実は僕のお母さんも来ていますくれています
[音楽]
僕はお母さんがいてお父さんがいておじいちゃんおばあちゃんもいて
でもちろん千頭はいます
みなさん自分の先祖のことって考えたこと今までありますか
あんまりないと思うんですよ
僕先日出張でインドに行ったんですけどその時にすごく衝撃を受けたのが
インド人現地の人がみんな自分の先祖のことをお話しできたんです
じゃ僕はいてもたってもいられなくなって日本に帰ってきたらすぐに実家に帰ってお
ばあちゃんと一緒に僕の先祖探しの旅っていうのにでました
その時に見つけたのがこれです僕の先祖は2000
ごめんなさいえっと1804年213年前に得なくなったサムライでした
今日は3年江戸時代です
この時自分の先祖のことを調べたのはもちろんなんですが
同時に今の現在僕が生きている世界とそしてこれからの200年後
どうなっていくんだろうそして僕らの子供とか
孫将来の人たちがすぐ住む世界のことを考えたんです
僕はサーフィンが大好きでものすごい大好きです
じゃあどれくらい好きかというとちょっと大会に出るぐらい好きです
で今でもサーフィンすごくするんですけどどう
サーフィン中に大学の時に出会った外国人の会社で働くことになりました
そして社会人になる前に3カ月間
すごく短気なんですけど英語を勉強しようとここで決めたのが
絶対にこのタイミングでたった3ヶ月だけど
英語をマスターして帰ってやろうと決めたんです
そして行く場所を迷った結果
ここになりました南国フィジです
サーフィンしちゃいますよね
その時僕お金なくて両親にお金を借りたんですけど今でもすごく感謝しています
でもこのサーフィンを通じてすごく僕は感動的な出来事に出会ったんです
サーフィン中に雨が降ってバケツをひっくり返したようなスコールが降るんです
そしてそのスコールが終わるとこんなに大きい虹が出て水が綺麗なんで水に反射して円
になるんですねその円の中をイルカが飛んで僕はそこから来た
おっきい波に乗るんです
多分に立った一瞬だと思うんですけどその波に乗って一瞬のことを忘れることができ
なかったんです
ただ同時に町に戻ってみるとへの前に起きている現象に衝撃を受けました
こんなにごみが落ちてるんだ
何も気づかずに歩いていれば
通り過ぎてしまっていたんですが僕はサーフィンですごく感動的な体験をしたので目の
前で起きていることに
責任を持って僕が解決し様邸
その時思ったんです
そして行動しようと決めました
フィジーは1970年にイギリスから独立した国です
現在人口90万人で旅行客は年間60万人に及びますそしてこのフィジーのゴミ
新がとかというある小さな町があるんですがその街の
1日に送られてくるゴミの6割はホテルからです
そしてホテルに宿泊するお客さんは観光客です2つまり
プラスチックや現地のゴミこれは自国生産をしていないフィジーでは作られていない
もので観光客が
その国に持って行ってステイて捨てているものなんですね
そしてこの現状を打破するためにどうしようと考えたところ
日本でよく見るポイ捨て禁止とかの看板ありますでもフィジにはそういう看板がなかっ
たんです
まずは看板作りから始めよう
そして
現地の人にゴミは良くないもので自分たちがどうにかしなきゃいけないんだっていう
ことを伝えようと決めたんです
看板を作るというのはフィジーでは簡単ではありませんでした車
僕の留学生活残り1週間を切っていました
学校の先生に僕は看板を作るだから学校早く卒業させてくれと言ったんです
そしたら
もともと学校から卒業するもしくは
学校をやめてしまうそうすると日本に強制帰国になってしまうから
それは出来ないって言われたんですね
でもある1人の先生が学校側と交渉してくれて僕の背中を押してくれました
そして僕のプロジェクトはスタートしました
看板を作る材料
僕らだったら
ショップに行けば買えますでもフィジーでは買えません
僕は材木屋に行って余っている
床材の柱をもらいましたそして黒のペンキ
天気はなかったので近くの車屋さんに行って黒の塗料をもらうもらいました
そして最後に筆なんですがどこにも売ってなかったんです筆を見つける
この行動自体がおかしいんじゃないかということで筆を作りました
近くのマンゴーの木の枝を撮ってそれを削って筆付でにしたんです
ねそうして描いた絵
メッセージが
keep our アップシーン
このメッセージボードを僕は近くの
乙あれ部という街の
バス停にかけました
ちゃらんぽらんな格好してますぼくう
この当時こんな格好してますけどここで伝えたいのは見た目じゃないよということです
で僕はですね a 周りでごみ拾いを始めたんですがある
ローカルの女子高生が一人手伝ってくれましたでも手伝うと同時に僕に聞いてきたん
です
何をしてるのをよくはサーフィンでこういう体験をしただから恩返しとしてこの思いを
伝えたいんだ
そしたら彼女がちょっと面白そうじゃん鉄だお
ってことで手伝い始めてくれたんですがそこからローカルみんなが手伝ってくれるよう
になってその場所のごみ拾いは終わりましたた大自然が豊かでゴミを隠してしまう
くらい
緑が豊富なのでそんな深い森の方まで僕
たちはゴミ拾いをすることができなかったんです
僕たちだけできないこと
これをするためには人に伝えなきゃいけない
そう思って僕は残り3日間
ごみ拾いを続けて
そして卒業式を迎えました
そして現地の留学先の卒業式で
スピーチをさせてもらったんです
そこにも一つハードルがあってぽくやスピーチをしようとしたときに英語でスピーチを
しなきゃいけなかったので先生にまた
3分だけ時間をくれって言ったんですねそしたらすぐ
お前の英語力じゃ無理だって言われたんですね
結局僕の留学生活で英語はあんまり上達しませんでした
でも片言の英語で
たった1分たった1分だけだったら時間をやるって言われて
スピーチをさせてもらいましたその時僕が伝えたメッセージは
別に全員に
今すぐゴミ拾いを始めろって言ってるんじゃないんです
でもこの先
80年間だったり
自分が生きている中でちょっとポケットにゴムがゴミが入ってたりとかあとはバッグの
中にある
画面のゴミだったりペットボトルしてちゃおっかなって思うときあると思うんですよ
でも
そんな時にあフィジーの留学先で
こんなこと言ってる奴がいたなですこ少しでいいんで
思い出してくれればいいそう思ったんです
そうしてこのメッセージを伝えて僕が帰国しました
オフィスで働いているとフェイスブックにある
通知が届いたんです
何だろうと思って開いてみると驚きました
一人の日本人が僕がやった活動を引き継いでくれたんです
そして
看板
同じメッセージを彼は匹ついてくれました
さらに僕が全くいないそして知ってるメンバーも少ない中
活動は拡大されていって
地元のみんなも手伝ってくれてます
さらに僕は地元のみんなにも笑顔を作れているたことが嬉しかったです
100人規模になりました
僕が知らない人たちもいっぱいます
そしてこの活動は
新聞に載るような活動も生まれてきました
ここで大事なのが誰がやったかではなくてどういうことが行われているか
そして将来に続くような世の中に良いことが文化として現地定着したってことが僕は
すごく嬉しかったんです
この中でですね
社会問題に対して
目を向けたことがある人って真剣に数えると
多くはないと思うんです
でも
過去の僕のセンズもそうですが
過去の先人たちはみんな世の中をより良くしていこうそしてもっと自分たちの組織を
発展させようと思っていろんなアプローチをしてきたはずなんです
例えば学術的なアプローチ政治的なアプローチ
宗教的なアプローチもそうだし社会的そして経済的なアプローチもいろんなアプローチ
の方法があると思うんです
でも
その反対側で
弊害っていうのも必ず生まれているはずなんですね
そしてその弊害ってどんなことがあって僕たちは考えたことあるかどうか
で僕は今世の中で
問題だと思うことそれは
問題を問題と気づいていないことだと思うんです
それが僕の中での社会に一番伝えたいメッセージであって
問題を問題として捉えることそこが第一ステップになるんだと思う
思うんです
だから僕は今バーチャルリアリティーといわれる
vr 新しいテクノロジーを使った会社でお仕事をしています
vr は画像と動画と違って今まで見ることでしか伝わらなかったことが体験として
伝えることを伝え伝えることができます
目の前のことに責任を持って行動すること
人間は
欲求とそして責任で行動することができます
例えば
誰かに好かれたい
かっこよくなりたい
お金持ちになりたいそういった欲求って誰でもあると思うんです
でもそういう欲求で行動をした人というのは
自分の中でその行動が止まります
その反面じゃあ責任を持って行動を始めた人はどうでしょう
責任を持った行動というのは人を動かします巻き込みます
だから僕は責任を持った人が行動を始めて人を巻き込んでほしいと思うんです
時に責任と言うと
江戸時代は切腹をすることとかそして今でも
退くこととかって考える人がいると思うんです全く違います
責任を持つということは目の前の事に諦めずに行動を続けることなんです
そしてその行動を続けるのであればしっかりこうやって人に伝えてあげてください
人に伝わると周りも応援してくれるはずなんです
目の前に個目の前のことに責任を持って行動する
僕がフィジーで行動したときもそうです
目の前で教えたゴミに責任を持って自分が今やらなきゃそう思ったから行動したんです
僕たちこれから200年後300年後に
より良い世界をつくっていくためにどうしたらいいか
人生はタスキの受け渡しです僕の先祖がやってきてくれたように僕たちも
一人一人がほんの少しだけ目の前のことに責任を持って行動していくだけで世の中は
きっとより良くなると思うんです
そして自分たちの200年後だったり300年後に良い正解をまだ続いて続けていき
たいと僕はすごく思っています
なので今日この中でたった一人でもいいので僕は目の前のことに責任を持ってくれる人
が増えるとすごく嬉しいです
この後電車で帰るかもしれないそして子供と遊ぶかもしれない
みんなの将来はそれぞれですでもその中で目の前で起きていることに責任を持って行動
してみてください
そうやって人の行動が変わっていくことで世の中は良くなります
そして行動すると人が応援しますもし応援されない人がいたら僕のところに来て
ください
僕は全力で応援します
ありがとうございました
[拍手]